y hablamos de economía en directo
américa de france a 24 ya daniel
hablando en esta lista con nosotros en
el estudio para hablar danny de los
principales exportadores de petróleo que
se reúnen para realizar el tema ruso
hola raúl muy buenos días pues mire el
grupo de la opep discute hoy si elevar o
no la producción del grupo más allá de
lo que ya está previsto es que eeuu les
ha pedido que reaccionen de esta manera
ante el encarecimiento de la energía y
yo bailé en inclusive estaría planeando
una visita a arabia saudita la opep para
más recordemos es un conjunto entre los
exportadores liderados por arabia
saudita y sus aliados liderados por
rusia y aunque hay informes que dicen
que rusia podría quedar excluida de este
grupo el kremlin ha desmentido todos los
rumores escuchados
otros con colegas de las monarquías
árabes planteamos el tema de la
permanencia rusa pero solo en el
contexto de la confirmación de los
acuerdos de cooperación dentro de la
opep más que ya han sido pactados y
confirmados varias veces por nuestros
líderes en este sentido los principios
de la cooperación conservan su
significado y relevancia
cómo amanecieron los precios de petróleo
entonces bueno pues mire el precio se ha
mantenido en más de 100 dólares desde el
inicio de la guerra y hoy como a ilusión
en el mercado de que se pueda aumentar
la oferta los precios están fuertemente
a la baja el mundo consume alrededor de
100 millones de barriles por día y se
estima que las sanciones occidentales
por la invasión con hacia ucrania han
sacado cerca de un millón de barriles
rusos ahí vemos cuánto bajan los precios
bueno y vamos a tener una noticia un
poco positiva en la unión europea porque
se redujo pero levemente en abril el
desempleo no va ni claro raúl los 27
países que conforman el bloque
comunitario registraron una tasa de
desocupación del 6,2 por ciento en este
mes estable frente a hace un mes pero
mucho más baja que el 7,5 por ciento de
hace un año
quiere decir que 13,3 millones de
personas no tienen empleo en la unión
europea y los más afectados son los
jóvenes sin embargo la cifra si ha
bajado y españa es un ejemplo de ello
mire aunque sigue teniendo la tasa más
alta del bloque según el gobierno hoy
tiene menos de 3 millones de personas
desempleadas por primera vez desde 2008
y por supuesto mía no es ajena a este
tema que estamos hablando toda esta
mañana con la reina no lo es y los
acontecimientos que marcan la vida de la
monarca no solamente tienen un valor
sentimental muy grande para los
británicos sino que también son un gran
negocio veamos lo que pasa en las
tiendas de londres en el siguiente
informe
los fanáticos de la realeza están
emocionados por el jubileo de platino de
la reina y lo demuestran también con su
dinero por lo que las boutiques de todo
londres están sacando provecho con
productos que conmemoran los 70 años de
reinado de isabel segundo
en este momento estamos vendiendo muchos
de estos platos puedes ver a la reina y
ella baila te saluda cuando hay luz es
una reina que funciona con energía solar
y vender light camp son sedantes o la
power ping
la reina es la más vendida superando con
creces a otros miembros de la familia
real
su majestad el símbolo de todo lo
británico para millones de turistas
comunal desde que estamos en londres
estamos buscando algo que no tenemos
ahora mismo estoy buscando saleros
la mayoría de los productos no están
avalados por el palacio de buckingham
pero otros si tienen el sello de
aprobación real algo que se refleja en
el precio de hecho la propia reina
supervisa algunos artículos como la
vajilla de porcelana para conmemorar su
jubileo cada pieza está hecha
minuciosamente a mano por artesanos
locales
hay un gran resurgimiento del made in
england y nosotros somos decididamente
una fábrica artesanal todos los miembros
de la familia real incluida su majestad
lo apoyan el té de la tarde también
sirve para celebrar el jubileo pequeños
pasteles que representan las joyas de la
corona de la reina y sus sombreros sobre
mousse de naranja incluso el carruaje en
el que viajará la gente esta capa
superior de postres es la más
espectacular gacha
me encanta como han pensado en cada
elemento de la vida de las reinas white
el jubileo de diamante de la reina en
2012 supuso unos 145 millones de euros
en ventas de merchandising su platino
promete aportar unas ventas aún mayores
como dirían algunos dignas de una reina
súper rápida ni a la que se compraría de
todo esto nada nada yo me compraría pues
por lo menos una tacita de té no para
tomar así sea tinto no gracias en él
aporta jaén porción económico nos vemos
más adelante con más ustedes continuar
con nosotros esto es directo américa